[Music]
[Music]
we have a few of viral foods that we're
gonna try out together I can grab a vine
roll the king of the pole seriously I do
anything fluffy and Japanese I love
[Music]
[Applause]
it's very dense which is amazing I can
fight through this across the room I
could probably knock somebody out so the
guys get ready this is a great it's
special I just thought it was gonna be a
lot sweeter
[Music]
every fun to like sit at like lunch with
this guy we can't sit you till the third
one gets here oh he's here
Oh bear down hibernating bear down bear
down let him go let him go let him go
your food goddess yeah now I've always
been posting pictures of food and
restaurants that I go to who they travel
so much and then once video and insta
stories happen it was like a whole new
world and within that minute or 15
seconds of Instagram to give like
something like personality to the dish
or the place I think it's really what
food got is you know I had this amazing
rainbow Pizza it's great I love cotton
candy anything
you